[Music]
hey guys it's joanna here so a lot of
you have been asking me to share
my updated meal plan what have i been
eating nowadays especially now that
we're spending a lot more time at home
so i'm going to be sharing with you my
favorite breakfast lunch and also dinner
for all of these meals you only need a
total of
20 ingredients yup that's right you know
me
i like to keep my meals really simple
really wholesome yet
really flavorful at the same time so
all the recipes are available on the
fuel app okay
so you can get all the recipes on the
field app you can also see
different meal plans to suit your
preference and also diet
i'm a pescetarian so today's meal plan
will be based around fish dishes
alright so for breakfast we're going to
be making
mushroom tuna egg muffins yup
really delicious as for lunch we're
going to be making
edamame soba noodle salad as well
as asian stir-fry salmon as for dinner
it will be
steamed barramundi with soy and ginger
and to serve it with mixed vegetables
i'm already hungry just by thinking of
all the dishes okay so let's start
with breakfast my
favorite egg muffins okay i am a savory
kind of person so i like to have
eggs in the morning and what i love
about this recipe is that it is
very versatile you can choose any of
your favorite vegetables
as well as ingredients so for example i
love tuna
and that gives me extra protein so i'm
going to have two now
and i'm going to have mushroom as well
as well as bell pepper so
finely dice all your vegetables okay and
it's really simple because
it's only literally two steps and pop it
in the oven and it's ready
in less than 15 minutes really simple
only four to five ingredients depending
on what you choose
okay so in a big bowl what you want to
do is mix
all the ingredients in so i'm going to
put my tuna in
okay this is about half a can of tuna i
mean during lockdown
or when you're staying at home i believe
most of you are buying canned foods
correct
lots and lots of canned foods so this is
a great way to use it and make
really awesome breakfast and
mushrooms so finely diced because we
want to make them into small muffins
all the mushrooms bell pepper
my favorite if you don't want to use
bell pepper you can also use carrots
or even vegetables like cucumbers so
it's really up to you pick your favorite
vegetables
the whole goal is to eat more veggies
even during breakfast
and now just mix it all evenly okay
just make sure it's all evenly mixed
all right set this aside okay now
you'll need about six eggs okay and this
should make you about six to eight
muffins depending on the size of
muffin tin or cups you're using break
all the eggs
into a bowl so now let's whisk the
eggs so now that all your ingredients
are ready
it's time to transfer them into
these cute little muffin cups
so start by placing the ingredients into
the muffin cups
so before you pour the egg into the
muffin tin you can choose to season your
eggs as well
i love to use the cajun seasoning
because
it's a little bit sweet but it has that
spice as well so i'm going to season
mine with a little bit of cajun spices
okay just to give it that nice kick
all right and of course
salt and pepper to taste as well
okay lots of salt and pepper
just to really elevate the flavor
okay now just give it a nice stir
and you want to also make sure that you
have preheated your oven to 185 degrees
celsius okay so while your oven is
pre-heating you can go ahead and prep
your muffins
so now slowly transfer the eggs into
each muffin
cup till it's about three quarter full
so once your oven has preheated place
the egg muffins into the oven and allow
it to bake for 15
to 20 minutes until they are all fully
cooked through okay it is really that
simple
and our egg muffins are ready as you can
see
it's slightly golden brown on the top
it's fully cooked through
and now leave it for about 10 to 15
minutes to cool down
before removing it from the muffin cups
okay
so this is a really simple breakfast you
can keep it really versatile by changing
the ingredients so that you won't get
bored
and you can also get your kids involved
in the kitchen
the great thing about these egg muffins
is that you can also use them as your
meal prep
so they will stay fresh in the fridge
for up to three days or
make them in large quantities and keep
them
in the freezer for up to a week so this
is a really simple
high protein breakfast for you to try
out
[Music]
this is so good usually for breakfast i
would have about
two to three muffins and sometimes i
will even bring this
out and have it at my post or even
pre-workout meal
so good and you get all the vegetables
and i love that
slight spicy taste of the tuna as well
you have to try it out
right lunch time i've been eating this
recipe i would say
almost every two days once asian salmon
stir-fried
served with my favorite edamame
soba noodle salad so it's a really great
combination
i mean i'm asian so i love the asian
flavors that goes into the dishes
so the main ingredient you'll need is a
salmon filet or more if you are making
it for a bigger family or a bigger
portion
and the vegetables i'll be using will be
french beans or long beans
as well as mushroom and of course we'll
need soba noodles
my favorite i love these noodles because
it's gluten free this noodle is actually
gluten free okay
and of course add mame so
really simple just steam your edamame
and just unshelter it
it is as simple as that so let's start
by prepping
our ingredients what you have to do is
dice
the salmon into cubes so now place
the salmon cubes into a bowl so we want
to season
the salmon with a little bit of soy
sauce before stir-frying it with the
vegetables
so just a little bit about one
tablespoon this will really bring out
the taste of the salmon i mean i can
even eat this raw right now but i won't
okay so just mix it allow it to sit for
about
10 to 15 minutes okay while the salmon
is marinating i'm going to go ahead and
prep
all my vegetables which i'll be using
for my salmon stir-fried
as well as for my dinner later on as
well
so i'm going to cut the spring onions
into
about one inch length and same thing
with the bell pepper slice it into long
strips
small chilies must have this in my meals
okay
it makes everything taste so much better
it brings up that slight spice
in the dishes so just finely slice it
if you can't take spice then of course
you can just emit this
from the recipe this is really spicy
so be sure to wash your hands don't
touch your face or your
eyes okay otherwise it's going to really
burn
[Music]
right so we're going to cook the soba
noodle make sure the water
is boiling before putting it in so this
one
bundle of soba noodle is about
90 grams okay and just leave it to cook
for about seven to ten minutes and
once you remove it you want to basically
soak it either in ice or cold water to
avoid the soba noodles from sticking
once your soba noodle is ready let's now
mix in
the rest of the ingredients okay i'm
going to mix mine with
edamame this is my favorite snack and in
fact
it is very high in protein so i like to
mix it in with
soba noodles or even just eat it as a
snack so mix it all in
so this is about a quarter cup of
edamame
okay so just mix it all and now to avoid
the noodles from sticking you can also
add a little bit of
sesame oil okay just drizzle i would say
about
one teaspoon all right just enough
okay and now mix in a little bit of
sesame seeds
and also don't forget my favorite
chili flakes okay so just
mix it in all right
and now just stir everything together
okay
make sure it's all equal and now just
garnish with
a little bit of spring onions
so this is done and this is good for two
portions okay so this is going to be my
main source of cups
for my lunch time to stir-fry this
salmon
so i'm using again sesame oil
if you don't have sesame oil don't worry
you can also use olive oil okay
so be don't don't go too crazy over your
oil just about
half a tablespoon is enough because
salmon is an oily fish so while you're
cooking the salmon it's going to produce
its own oil as well
i'm going to put in a little bit of
garlic cloves about
two garlic cloves garlic mix everything
better alright so stir-fry your garlic
until
it's golden brown and fragrant
let's stir in our marinated salmon
okay
oh it's sizzling
all right so just gently
toss it around and cook it
until it turns pink
[Music]
as you can see the salmon has turned
pink and it's slightly golden
so we want to allow it to cook until at
least 70
done before we add the rest of the
vegetables in
okay so you can also mix it around a
little bit just be gentle to avoid
breaking the salmon
all right so this is almost ready now
let's add in the vegetables
so your beans okay just put it
all in lots and lots of vegetables okay
this dish is great because you get
protein
as well as vegetables all in just one
dish
so it's really simple as well okay now
let's mix it up a little bit
okay so we want to add a little bit of
water as well to avoid
the vegetables and salmon from sticking
okay and just a little bit more
soy sauce okay just a little bit not too
much
otherwise you're gonna complain it's too
salty just a little bit
as you can see the vegetables are tender
the salmon is fully cooked through
so this is now ready okay
so because i like spicy food i'm going
to put a little bit of chili flakes
just to have that slight kick in my dish
okay so again this is optional if you
love spice
have more chili okay
just mix it all together and this dish
is ready
and for the final touch just garnish it
with
a little bit of spring onions
lunch is ready so i have the edamame and
soba noodles
salad served with salmon stir-fried with
green beans as well as mushroom
so this is a really simple dish but a
very complete
dish so my source of cups will be the
soba noodles and my source of protein
will be salmon
and i'm loading this dish with lots of
vegetables
again a really simple dish which you can
prep ahead and bring it out with you
really delicious and simple
it's dinner time for dinner i love to
have
my steamed fish so i promise you this is
going to be
the easiest and simplest recipe for you
to prep it's extremely quick to prep
and rather quick to cook as well so it's
going to be steamed barramundi with
soy and ginger chinese or asian people
we love
our steamed fish you can even steam the
whole fish for your entire family
or you can even steam a fish filet for
one or two servings okay so the fish i'm
using today
is barramundi if you want to you can
also use halibut
or even tilapia so choose your favorite
fish
probably choose white fish okay so it
will really soak
all the flavors in as i've mentioned
really really simple ingredients
so what i have here is ginger okay
finely sliced ginger
spring onion you can't cook steamed fish
without spring onion
okay and chili okay this is optional
if you don't like it spicy then you can
omit this for this recipe you want to
use a deep plate okay so now let's start
prepping the fish first thing is to
place your sliced
ginger onto the plate okay lots of it
remember to be generous with your ginger
and now place a little bit of spring
onions at the bottom as well
just a little bit all right
that should be enough and now
i promise you it's really simple isn't
it so take your fish or your fish fillet
place it on top all right and
we want to repeat the same step again so
same thing remember be generous with
your ginger
lots and lots of ginger slices this will
also help you to cover
any fishy smell that you might not like
so if you want to
finish up all the ginger alright
and same thing spring onion okay
all right and now optional
if you love spice like me have some
small
chili on top so as you can see i'm not
putting too much
otherwise it's going to be really spicy
just
a little bit okay done right so now
to really bring out the umami flavor of
the dish
you have to use soy sauce all right soy
sauce
not too much just a little bit just to
really bring out
the umami flavor of the dish so just
drizzle
a little bit of soy sauce i would say
about one tablespoon
okay all around the fish and now
sesame oil just a little bit again
not too much as well just a little bit
and this will really
keep your fish really fragrant and for
that
really silky texture as well all right
that's it this dish is done
and now we want to steam this for about
15 to 20 minutes long until the fish is
fully cooked
through to steam the fish don't worry if
you don't have a steamer at home okay
because
i don't have a steamer as well but
here's a really simple trick that you
can do
so use a large pan okay a large enough
and a deep enough pan
and just fill it up with hot water or at
least warm water okay
and all you have to do is simply place
this plate of
fish into the pan okay
all right as you can see my water is
about half
to three quarter full so don't fill it
up too much
that the water spills into the dish okay
so this is ready and now all you have to
do is cover it
and allow it to steam for about 20
minutes and your fish will be ready it
is that simple so this is a really
simple
diy steamer for you to use at home
look at this extremely simple extremely
flavorful and this is just
perfect to be eaten whether it's dinner
lunch in fact
every day i have this really often at
home
so steamed barramundi with ginger and
soy
again you can choose any other white
fish of your choice
i am so ready to eat so to go along with
my steamed
fish i'm going to be cooking stir-fried
mixed vegetables
so the thing i love about this recipe
again it is very
versatile you get to choose your
favorite vegetables
and basically mix and match so today
i'll be using
broccoli carrots as well as bell pepper
so this recipe is very similar to the
salmon stir fry okay
so again heat up your pan add a little
bit of
sesame oil or olive oil just a little
bit
just enough to coat the pan so let's add
in
the garlic again use about two to three
cloves okay
be generous with your garlic
so stir fry for about one to two minutes
until they are golden brown
smells really good i mean honestly
just by having garlic ginger and onion
in your cooking
everything smells and tastes really good
now let's mix
in the broccoli and carrots first not
the bell pepper because
broccoli and carrots takes longer to
cook okay
so just the broccoli
slice them into small florets
all right so all the broccoli
and the carrots as well
so thin slices and now just add a little
bit of water
and now just cover it so that the
broccoli and carrots will start to
become
tender and once it's tender that's when
we'll add the bell peppers
into the dish so just leave it for about
three to five minutes so you'll notice
that
the broccoli and carrots are tender
right now
by this time you can add in the bell
pepper
okay this dish is really colorful it's
really flavorful
and you got to eat more vegetables okay
so be sure to always accompany your
protein or cups
with lots and lots of vegetables and now
i'm going to once more mix in a little
bit of chili flakes
okay a little bit of chili flakes
and also a little bit of soy sauce just
a little
this is ready look at the colors
we have green red and orange remember to
eat your five a day
this is how your dinner should look like
colorful flavorful and
extremely simple i prepped all of this
in less than 30 minutes
and i'm sure your family will be very
happy to
eat this so we have our steamed fish
which is beautifully cooked
we have our colorful vegetables have
lots of this okay
and i'm serving it with a bowl of white
rice
so be sure to control your portion okay
if you're looking to maintain your
weight
then one small bowl will be great if
however
you're looking to lose weight then go
with half a bowl of
white rice okay and the trick here is to
use chopsticks
i mean this is something that i often
talk about and joke about as well
asians tend to use chopsticks to enjoy
their dishes and the trick with using
chopsticks is that
you will tend to take smaller bites you
will eat slower
and you will really enjoy your food and
feel satisfied
with less so instead of just scuffing it
down and finishing all your meals and
feeling
really stuffed afterwards by using
chopsticks
you will start to slow down the pace of
your eating and you will stop when you
know you're about 80
full so that will actually stop you from
overeating and help you with portion
control as well
so i am really looking forward to taste
this fish
it is it should be really flaky
ah perfectly cooked
perfectly seasoned perfectly cooked
and this is something that i really
enjoy with my family
so these are all my meals for the day as
you can see i've only used
20 ingredients to prep all these
dishes again they are really simple they
are really awesome
and really delicious as you can see i've
used
really simple and healthy cooking
methods such as light stir frying
or steaming baking as well as boiling
so by using these healthier cooking
methods it will really help you to
reduce on your calorie intake and
therefore you will be able to eat
healthier
live healthier and it will also help you
to maintain a healthy weight for life
again all these foods are real food
therefore you will feel satisfied and it
will also help you to reduce
your food portion and avoid overeating
as we're spending more time at home
this is a great opportunity for you to
start to learn to cook
by starting with really simple dishes
and really
take this time to start to practice
healthy eating
right at home okay so be sure to try
these recipes out let me know which is
your favorite in the comments below
and if you enjoy knowing more about what
i eat in a day
let me know in the comments below as
well and hopefully i will be able to
share
more meal prep recipes with all of you
if you want more healthy recipes and
also more meal prep ideas
then go onto my youtube channel and
check out my previous videos
and don't forget to also hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet done
it
be sure to download fuel app and check
out all the recipes in fuel
okay and i will see you in my next
cooking video
all the best
[Music]
you